und zwar ist das der op von tübingen der
das als erste stadt so genannte schweden
regeln einführen will dass es die seite
2 der bild zeitung von morgen und zwar
owe palma möchte in diesem zusammenhang
die alten besser schützen er möchte
dafür sorgen dass die älteren zu
bestimmten einkaufszeiten rausgehen und
dass sie nicht mehr busse benutzen
möglichst fahrrad fahren oder im sammel
taxi unterwegs sind und das ist das
zitat er sagt der tübinger appell setzt
wie schweden auf eigenverantwortung und
besonderen schutz der alten herr
dobrindt kann das modell für deutschland
sagen da kann man sich ja mal schweden
anschauen wenn das das dass das ist was
der oberbürgermeister hier will in
schweden die zahlen heißen dass genau
eine generation nämlich die ältere die
lasten dieser politik zu tragen hat wenn
man stockholm und münchen miteinander
vergleicht pro 100000 einwohner sind in
stockholm 16 mal so viele menschen
verstorben wie in münchen aber da gibt
es ja nur statistik da geht es ja um die
statistik gut aber für die politik dies
weder sagen sie hätten jetzt daraus
gelernt weil sie sagen dass sie
sozusagen alten und pflegeheime jetzt
besser schützen und deswegen auf mehr
eigenverantwortung setzen können lindner
ist das modell was der thüringer
oberbürgermeister tübinger
oberbürgermeister fährt was ihnen für
ganz deutschland vor schwer
ich rate ab davon dass wir uns mit
schweden vergleichen das modell schweden
ist in deutschland politisch
argumentativ verbrannt die schweden
haben auch fehler gemacht sich
korrigiert also der schweden sagt man
völlig unterschiedliche dinge aber ich
halte es ebenfalls für richtig dass wir
um das wort von frau merkel noch einmal
aufzunehmen eine nationale
kraftanstrengung organisieren mit allem
was wir an ressourcen und kreativität
haben die menschen die schutzbedürftig
sind so zu schützen dass sie nicht
vereinsamen
das bedeutet etwa die tests strategie
des bundes in allen ländern umsetzen bis
ins einzelne pflegeheim damit die
pflegekräfte und die reinigungskräfte
fortwährend getestet werden von da wird
nämlich das virus eingeschleppt
gleichzeitig da die besten masken zur
verfügung stehen fb2 masken für alle die
dort ein und aus gehen also
sportschützen in der nachbarschaft
schützen und selbstverständlich müssen
wir uns als jüngere auch zurücknehmen es
geht nicht um partys es geht sehr wohl
auch im kontakt beschränkungen eine
wenige leute einige wenige leute
vielleicht auch nur zwei haushalte aber
zumindestens muss es eine strategie sein
die durch haltbar ist und ich weiß nicht
die sieben modelle haben wir werden das
war ein gesehen zwei kolleginnen und der
kollege stimmen vielleicht zu oder auch
nicht so wie wir das jetzt machen das
können wir doch nicht bis februar märz
nächsten jahres durchhalten bis wir
einen impfstoff haben
und da sagt ja nicht nur ich sondern es
sind über 30 bürgermeister von cdu spd
und anderen parteien also über 30
oberbürgermeister aus allen parteien
haben einen dringenden appell geäußert
das bitteschön gastronomie das
beherbergung dass kultur offen bleiben
das ist nicht nur ein fdp thema sondern
die menschen die in den städten
verantwortung tragen quer über alle
parteien über 30 oberbürgermeister
richten den appell an euch gemeinsam
sollten jedoch das ernst nehmen also ich
sag mal wenn ich muss ihm über christian
ich muss dir sagen was wir nicht
durchhalten
in den letzten 14 tagen haben sich die
belegungen der intensivbetten in
deutschland verdoppelt die nächsten 14
tagen der verdoppelung und die 14 tage
darauf eine verdoppelung und wir sind
über dem was wir an intensivbetten zur
verfügung haben das halten wir nicht
durch und weil das und in der formel 1
das ist das minimum mit dem mit dem wir
jetzt arbeiten lassen
und da widerspreche ich jawohl wir
halten das mit der verdoppelung der
belegung nicht durch deshalb müssen wir
maßnahmen ergreifen die begrenzung der
persönlichen kontakt die reduzierung auf
zwei haushalte einverstanden das ist ein
wirksames mittel
die schutzkonzepte in den
pflegeeinrichtungen die sind noch alles
andere als optimal
da würde ich sagen hält die
argumentation wir tun da schon alles dem
auf einer baracke einer praktischen
überprüfen können wir gerne mal schnell
test
gern auch finanziell ein angebot ist
zusammen mit der bild besuchen wir fünf
pflegeeinrichtungen und fragen mal wie
das in der praxis läuft das besser
werden kann wenn du es machst du da nach
sicherheit besser werden auf jeden fall
ansteuern sollten wir das bei aber dann
schauen wir auch an meinen letzten
jahren und monaten einverstanden aber
gastronomie hotellerie museen also
museum zu schließen
also das sind die bereiche wo doch genau
nachgeschaut werden kann wer geht rein
da also doch es gibt noch keine marica
oder sondern auch im protokoll also sie
gehen gemeinsam mit herrn lindner und
uns durch die pflegeheime und schauen
sich das an der sofort ja keine frage
weil wir auch sehen wollen natürlich was
kann man auch besser machen aber wir
schauen auch an was man derzeit alles
gemacht haben interessant ist doch nur
die argumentation immer zu sagen oh mein
gott was kommt noch alles im
dezember/januar wir können das doch
alles über solange nicht aushalten und
gleichzeitig zu sagen dass man
eigentlich viel weniger haben will
also entweder ja es ist so wenig dass
wir so lange vor uns noch her tragen
müssen dass wir wieder nicht zurück
können verstehe ich nicht da ist ganz
einfach wenn das was wir jetzt tun
zu viel ist ja dass wir erst im dezember
im januar im februar nochmals
verschärfen müssen das sind ja deine
befürchtungen nein dann kannst du auf
der anderen seite habe ich sagen da alle
fest was wir jetzt schon machen du nicht
haben bleibt mein team und ich wir
entscheiden meine befürchtung den schutz
der bevölkerung jetzt ja oder sagen wir
es hat noch ein bisschen zeit also das
sind schein alternativen ich bin auch
den schutz der bevölkerung ich glaube
nur dass die maßnahmen nicht wirksam
sind das die wirksamen maßnahmen
verlängert werden können einverstanden
nur die unwirksame maßnahmen sollten wir
eben nicht verlängern und ich bleib
dabei gastronomie zu schließen das ist
eine unwirksame maßnahmen in angriff
ich mach's noch einmal frau schwesig
mittels gesprächen verschickt wir haben
heute auch einen sehr dramatischen
appell des saarländischen
ministerpräsidenten gehört in der bild
am sonntag vor einem kollaps der
kliniken gewarnt und hat gesagt das
könnte schon bald so weit sein sie sind
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern
wie sieht es in ihren kliniken aus und
teilen sie diese einschätzung dass wir
da vor einem kollaps stehen könnten
schon in naher zukunft